brent musburger himself how are you
Brent I'm fine rich how are you this
morning
I am I am wondering what you thought of
the news from yesterday sir well you
know we've been expecting that because
whenever the Supreme Court decides to
review a lower court's ruling it's
around ninety percent that they're going
to overturn it and so certainly they did
in this particular case however my
advice is New Jersey is to move quickly
to implement it and I get late word this
morning that that's exactly what they're
going to do that Monmouth racetrack says
they will be open for betting on
individual sports on Memorial Day May
28th coming up and a reason for that and
and you alluded to the fact that the
court said that the professional and
amateur sports Protection Act which we
call pass by was unconstitutional
however in his majority opinion and I am
sure that the NFL attorneys along with
the NBA attorneys notice this one
sentence from Justice Samuel Alito
he wrote that quote Congress can
regulate sports gambling directly okay
and so the NFL and the NBA are both out
and they came out yesterday and said
that they hope that Congress can step in
and make an overall law regulating
sports gambling which means that of New
Jersey is open for business as Nevada
was in 1992 they can be grandfathered in
and they can manage their own sports
wagering account so it is just beginning
which across the country already we've
had a battle break out in Connecticut
between the Indian controlled casinos up
there in the state the state has
withdrawn legislation the battle in
California will be waged between the
racetracks and the Indian authorized
casinos so the battle royale is going to
continue across the landscape however
I'm fully expecting New Jersey to be
open for business for the
upcoming NFL season so what do you say
Brent to those who are concerned about
the integrity that the low-paid wide
receiver the potential college student
if it reaches that will throw something
for for whatever amount of cash because
gambling will be so much more prevalent
or easier to to undertake what do you
say to that Brent I suppose the same
thing I would say for an alcoholic
walking past a bar that obviously we
have to be vigilant in in every
particular area and I would point out
and no one is more of a journal about
the moving of money when it comes to
betting on individual games then the
bookmakers themselves if you go behind
the counter of any sports book here in
Las Vegas
the computers run 24/7 and you can see
exactly where the money is being wagered
not just here in the United States but
but around the globe and no one keeps a
closer eye on it I've always been
concerned about which about the
collegiate athlete because they are not
paid at all
however I've come to the conclusion that
if it was not allowed in the United
States that people would continue to bet
on the college games illegally auction
we're better off happiness a regulated
market certainly they're gonna be
problems have been problems worldwide
with a certain friendly soccer matches
played in faraway places where the evil
intense have taken over results you
always have baby they've been aware of
that for a long long time and so I don't
think that that changes in any
particular regard I would be very very
surprised if the third-string wide
receiver was vulnerable simply because
he's being paid he knows what the rules
are
it stated when he signs that contract he
sees inside the locker room in the
National Football League and I would be
shocked if because the third-string wide
receiver probably probably is not going
to be in a position where he can impact
the outcome of a game one way or another
back in the days when there were rumors
galore about professional football
players had always centered on one
position and that was the quarterback
hall-of-famer Brent Musburger joining me
here on the Rich Eisen show so how does
the money work then Brent I mean we just
had Don Van Natta on and I asked him the
question of how the sports leagues are
gonna try to wet their beak unions
players etc and I mentioned how you last
time you were on on this subject on this
show laughed off the notion from the
Commissioner of the NBA Adam Silver in
an op-ed piece that that a percentage
will just be cut to sports leagues that
that would not fly with towns like yours
or anybody else who's in this business
how does it work
where those sports leagues now want to
get their piece if it's all legal and
aboveboard
well obviously they're gonna have to
negotiate with each of the individual
states that was the ruling yesterday
unless there's a federal law passed
regarding that what it basically shows
is everybody's been worried about the
integrity but now that it looks like
it's going to become legal everybody
wants a piece of the action and and I
would say look look to the Premier
League and the other major soccer
associations look down to Australian
rules football and see what happens is
an increase in television ratings
probably would be encouraged so you
raise the rates your product is worth
more money Mark Cuban said that the
value of the top four teams in each of
the league's had basically doubled
yesterday no not sure I agree with that
assessment but I'm sure that the value
went up and also if you take a close
look at the Premier League at least half
of those teams have agreements with the
different betting concerns like
Ladbrokes
some of them even wear uniforms that are
attached to sports gambling and
obviously if they made agreements with
individual bookmakers you are the
bookmaker of the New York Giants or
whatever in in years past as a business
agreement between two parties but trying
to get a tax which has never existed
here in the state of Nevada there's no
such thing as an integrity fee the
league is responsible for for marketing
own product and I'm sure they would like
to get a piece of the action I don't
think there's any question about that
some of the teams in the NFL obviously
have financial agreements with the
fantasy sites which was very interesting
because those fantasy sites came out
until yesterday and said hey this is
this a game of skill this is not
gambling yeah game came out yesterday
and quickly said hey we're ready to go
into the sports betting so there you
have it
it's amazing brent musburger few words
for brent here on this subject and you
touched upon it so let's say TV ratings
do go up as people expect and television
contracts get more expensive and then
wouldn't you think TV networks would
want to try and get in this business
themselves and start just flat-out
communicating to gamblers through the
television sets through the radio
speakers through internet connections
and in that regard well how do you see
TV networks and sports networks covering
this sort of stuff that you have already
been on the ground floor of Brent yeah I
think that obviously it will expand and
and the various networks will go and
they will have shows like ours here at
be sent dedicated to the betting I would
think that the pregame shows which would
probably let's just take the NFL Network
down the road I would think that the at
least the crawl at the bottom of it
would probably have the the updated odds
in the over/under numbers on the games
and that you yourself with some of the
analysts on the NFL will become more
acceptable around the league for you to
talk about hey you know they've got the
wrong favorite in this Atlanta
Philadelphia game I think if you bogged
down in the minutia of the numbers the
six and a half and a half things like
that I think that becomes pretty boring
after a while I mean there's only a
certain segment of the of the population
that's really really involved with all
of those numbers I think everybody is in
the very interested in what the number
is who's the favorite in this game and
how big a favorite are there that's that
certainly to me has always been part of
the information base and I
I'm talking specifically about the about
the National Football League although
what was interesting I noted when you
talked about the people in the NBA and
the Western Conference how it's over
it's fascinating to me because the
Houston Rockets are a slight favorite in
the second game and I suspect that's
based upon the zigzag theory which you
have and obviously it'll be a do or die
game for Houston if they're gonna stay
alive at all they've got a win game too
now there's a certain percentage of the
population that's interested in that
will make a bet most of the population
will not they'll they'll watch the game
but they would be interested to know
that the Houston Rockets are favored
even though they were blown out by Kevin
Durant and the Warriors in in Game one
but there will be specific shows about
series prices and where we stand after
four weeks of a season and things like
that you can always make it interesting
to the to the general public do you
think it will ever Brent get to the
point where sports leagues will allow or
award rights holders status to
organizations like yours where the
play-by-play somebody like yourself or
an analyst isn't just describing the
action but describing the action in
relation to the line right yeah there
will be like multiple channels in which
they they certainly will do that because
they know based on experience right now
that most of the gambling on sports in
Europe is in-game and so that as the
game goes on obviously you you take a
channel and let's say it's a gym Nansen
and normal you're doing the play-by-play
that will always exist that that that's
not going to change for sure and that
will have the majority of the audience
but you could run another channel at the
same time somewhat similar to the
redzone channel in that you would update
the scores but you would also update the
changing line based on the scores of the
game and you would put the halftime
numbers up and the
under numbers there's no there's no
reason why that won't exist and that
would be another stream of revenue for
the leagues as they would sell lydia the
exclusive rights to something like that
my guys own has been so successful for
them my guys here in the studio because
you know you say you have your guys here
in the desert my guys in the studio just
went nuts over that what do you want to
call that we want to call it the best
own channel brands own channel there we
go
believe bait you'd have a hell of an
audience for it well in the meantime
Brent I guess just to wrap this up
you're saying that we on NFL gameday
morning on NFL Network should look for a
certain gentleman from say the country
of Greece who might know the line and
have our own Greek on our program very
shortly it'll come full circle that
you're saying yes yes exactly we need a
young Greek no question about it
what would he think last one what do you
think he would think about this day
Brent Jimmy I think you have a big smile
on his face you know he was back in the
in the beginning and was the first
legitimate contact was betting on the
NFL to make an appearance on a on a
pregame show I think he'd be very
satisfied and and hopeful it'll be
monitored like it should be legally and
I've caught the Greek was kind of
interesting in that way you know he came
he came from the from the dark side came
over to the bright side and and he
always wanted it to be run efficiently
and honestly in the end and so he'd be
very happy with where we are today
Brent love the chats as always thanks
for joining on everybody we'll be
listening to you opine on this subject
no doubt for forevermore my guys in the
desert on V sin on Sirius XM every
single day 3:00 to 5:00 Pacific time out
there in Las Vegas thanks for the call
Brent always enjoy it thanks Rach okay
that's Brent Musburger the Rich Eisen
show weekdays at noon eastern on
audience